el día previo a las elecciones en irán
está prohibido las campañas electorales
pero esto no significa que no haya
movimiento respecto a lo que puede pasar
mañana y en este caso está enfocado
especialmente en la campaña para
movilizar a los iraníes a que participen
en estas elecciones según las encuestas
sólo el 42% de los 59 millones de
iraníes habilitados para votar
participarían en las elecciones lo que
ha llevado al líder supremo a ser un
movimiento bastante inusual en él y es
que ayer se dirigió a la población
invitándolos a votar pero también
diciendo que una baja participación
sería utilizado por los enemigos de irán
y hablo que estos enemigos estaban
utilizando todas estas herramientas
políticas y mediáticas para crear la
idea de que estas elecciones iban a
tener una baja participación pero la
realidad es muchísimo más compleja que
está la apatía de los iraníes viene
desde hace meses atrás especialmente por
las promesas incumplidas en el campo
económico cada vez es más difícil la
situación pero también por qué
piensan que no importan a quien elijan
el poder está en un nivel más alto
especialmente en el líder supremo y
ellos creen que desde hace rato el jefe
de la justicia iraní el candidato y
brain rice y que está a mis espaldas es
el señalado por el sistema para hacer el
próximo presidente pero eso lo sabremos
mañana cuando sepamos cómo van las
elecciones